hello everyone I wanted to wrap up the
Star Wars discussion that I started a
few weeks ago on what I had people
appeared to me as being somewhat
confused symbolism in the Star Wars
imagery of the force and the first thing
I have to say is I was amazed at
everybody how they participated in this
I mean I was really excited to read all
your comments I think after I think
after three days there were there was at
least 65 comments and so at first I
tried to keep up and to answer every one
but after a while I just I just couldn't
keep up but I mean I read all the
comments and it made me think a lot
about about the symbolism and I have to
say some of your ideas that some of the
ideas that people gave me were really
great the best idea I think that came
out of this was that we're dealing in
this in the Star Wars story with an
exceptional situation let's say a kind
of end of the world situation where
things are upside down and so I think
that makes a lot of sense and and a lot
of people pointed out that there's a
definite tension between between Darth
Vader the Emperor and the other aspects
of the Empire and some people pointed
out for example the scene where Vader
chokes the leaders you can see that
there's this it's kind of annoyance you
know people the the commanders of the of
the Death Star and the commanders of the
of the Empire they hate the this kind of
superstitious thing and at the same time
Vader he has he finds their their lack
of faith disturbing signs your lack of
faith disturbing as it says in the movie
so that's really what came out the most
and I really it helped me to help me to
understand what it could mean and the
fact that the in a way the Empire only
lasts what is it like 20 years someone
pointed that out on Facebook to me shows
that it's really an end of the world
situation where extremes come together
to create this crazy destructive thing
and then everything just falls apart and
so so that was interesting there's still
some issues that I have with why the
Jedi's why the light side of the force
would be on the side of
this kind of rebellious group and
democracy but maybe there's there's
something to do with the story of Elijah
which I've pointed out before in other
videos about how in the story of Elijah
everything is upside down and the
prophet of God actually ends up being a
furtive character who has to hide in a
cave and so so yeah so I'm surprised
that I hadn't thought of that myself so
I really appreciate everybody's input
I'm going to be I'm trying with hoping
to make more videos I'm it's going to
take a few weeks before I make more
because I'm preparing for a talk that
I'm going to give it a few weeks in
Tennessee which is called Pentecost for
the zombie apocalypse and so I'm
preparing that hopefully it'll be a very
interesting talk and I'll try to find a
way to get it filmed and put it on on my
channel so that everybody can see it
I think it'll be thinking will be
interesting so everybody thanks for for
following me and I'll see you in a few
weeks